[Music]
SC out to Salt Lake City and talk to
Janelle what's up
Janelle hey I'm good can you hear me I
can how are you okay I am very nervous I
cannot believe that I'm actually talking
to you I can't believe I'm talking to
you I am so grateful and hope that you
can give me words of wisdom today I will
do my best what's up
so my question is how do you live with
someone that has BPD or borderline
personality disorder and the guilt that
comes along with that and so the
background is um my son who is an adult
he's
23 the precipitating uh thing is is
that we he's had
several I I wouldn't say
suicide attempts necessarily but
definitely very strong threats of
suicide um and then this last month he
was pulled over um for having um an
equipment malfunction on his car but
also had an open container in the car
and refused to talk to the police and
the cars registered in my husband's name
so they called
him and said look you know uh we're have
your son pulled over you know can you
get him to talk to us and anyway it was
a long drawn out event night he ended up
deciding to go to a hospital on the
72-hour hold instead of going to
jail and um
so long story short he there were no
beds anywhere in the state of Utah for
him to go to an inpatient place so I had
to go and pick him up and get him out
but I had told him you cannot live with
us anymore because drinking and driving
was one of our hard stop you cannot do
this while you live
here and so
um then he left and he came home for one
night left and went to be with someone
who lives out of state a friend and came
back the week
later in the
meantime I called his therapist which is
the first time I've ever done that I've
never had any contact with his therapist
ever but I was like okay he's in a bad
situation in bad spot thought um
threatening suicide again left the
state and his therapist kind of LED with
well people with borderline personality
disorder this is a you know suicidal
threats and stuff are commment and I
just went
what like it was
so it was such a validation of
everything that we've dealt with with
him over the last however many years
wait hold on the therapist gave you your
son's
diagnostic yes only because like he told
me initially first you need to call back
and leave your message I will listen to
your message and if I have questions I
will call you back gotcha okay so I said
okay so I called and left a message and
told him what was going on and he called
back and he said because this is a
safety issue because he's threatening so
suicide okay and now you know you're not
in contact with him and you don't know
where he is this is the only reason that
I can talk to you okay all right I want
let's pause let's pause here for a
second I want to do this um I want to
take a second or a minute or two if
that's okay and teach for just a second
okay to everybody listening borderline
personality disorder you heard me
exhale you heard mom go I knew
it here's what borderline personality
dis and by the way I love love these
folks
and man I'm a pretty differentiated guy
and so if you walk away from me that's
fine um and my kids don't have it or
they haven't been diagnosed with it yet
um here's borderline personality
disorder your feelings feel like
fire and so they experience the world
differently than other people so were
you the a listener casual listener you
get mad they get
enraged you like somebody you meet them
at a at a bar and you like them you meet
them at church and you like
them their body is a wash in love I love
them and I love them forever and ever
amen
until they're four minutes late and then
I
hate them they're the worst I destroy
them right and so there's this obsession
with abandonment and it's often imagined
it's often not real like four minutes
late right I had I I was going to the
bathroom and I came out and by the time
you get there that annoyance like let's
say someone's late five minutes late to
a date I can feel
it and then when I see them and I go
where were you and they go oh I had to
go run to the bathroom I go okay often
somebody with borderline personality
sort of can't come back when that train
leaves the station one way way or the
other it is gone best ever worst ever
there is no middle
ground and and counselors we know when
somebody comes in and says hey I've seen
six counselors you're the greatest
counselor of all time you're the only
one that has ever got
me counselors go uh oh right because
here we're gonna be on the other side
and very very impulsive so here's a
here's a picture I want to paint for
somebody who doesn't know what this is
imagine you're walking through the woods
on a hike and you're surrounded all of a
sudden bees are all over your arms and
legs and they're stinging you all over
you would roll run flop scream jump in a
lake cover yourself with leaves you do
whatever you could to get these bees off
of you if somebody was to be 200 yards
from you and just see you acting they
would think oh no this person's bananas
b an N but to you it makes perfect sense
you're getting stung by bees right so if
you've got borderline personality
disorder one of the strong
characteristics is highly impulsive and
often irres irresponsible Behavior so
when your body when your feelings feel
like
fire you go sleep with four people over
a two-day period you go you don't drink
you
drink right y you don't tell somebody
hey I I can't talk to you
today you burn them to the ground or I
feel like I can't get a hold of mom I'm
just going to tell Mom I'm I'm thinking
about hurting myself or what a classic
line is I'm having dark dark thoughts
and then everybody comes back right it's
this intensity this paranoia an actual
fear of something that folks around them
often can't even see or experience very
black or white they call it splitting it
is this or this period right either or
not both
and so am I hitting am I that that's
borderline personality disorder in a
nutshell and the reason I love you
completely you completely put my son in
that nutshell Okay the reason I love
them is they experienced the world in
such a
multicolorful way a powerful way they I
I'm I'm jealous of how joyful they can
be and here's what's super frustrating
they're often brilliant brilliant
brilliant mm and when they tell
me I hate you I'm able to walk away like
well my wife loves me and my kids mostly
do so I'm my dogs like me so um it's
hard when you're a mom right oh my gosh
mom guilt is the worst thing on the face
of the planet that's right and you have
probably done the terrible thing which
is Google borderline personality
disorder and somewhere they've said it's
it's got a strong genetic link and
you've gone oh I did this to
him well yes but the other part of that
also is everything that I've read is
saying that it's a lot of it
almost every case is trauma
in I'm
like to my knowledge there has been no
abuse to my knowledge like we have a
really tight close family and I just
kind of
go okay how is there
trauma for him and did I cause it and
what so let me tell you let me tell you
the problem let me tell you the the
scary thing about the track you're on
and then please just stop the train
where it is okay number one I was with
my wife for 25 years and there are some
things I didn't tell her about what I
experienced as a kid yeah just because
you're tight doesn't mean you don't you
know right the second thing is that
question that you start asking we're a
tight-knit family and what about this
all if you're not careful ends up in
what about
me what did I
do right and his pain and his experience
of the
world somehow becomes your
issue it somehow becomes what about what
about me and with the B someone
struggles with borderline it can never
it can never loop back that
way yeah I mean it's like seriously he
has been this way his as far as I I mean
I his mom and I gave birth to him as far
as I know and have can look back at his
entire life he has been like
this like his siblings would get mad
because I would just be like hey look
he's just different like he feels things
intensely so when he's mad he's pissed
yeah and when he's happy he's over the
moon happy and I so I've always his
whole life explained him that way to
people
right and so I don't know I'm like so
now that he is no longer living with
us we went down
today mostly my husband because I
couldn't do it because I cried the whole
time okay to the room that he was
staying in and I
said I just feel like I'm betraying him
by packing up his stuff in your in your
house in my house and my husband
said you know he has to start learning
the consequences of his adult choices
and I'm like I know but as a mom I
cannot like it's
so hard the greatest gift you can give
him is both I see
you and I believe
you and here are my
boundaries it's the greatest gift you
can give feel so guilty as the mom
setting boundaries I know and that's
that's
a
those feelings you
feel you're asking him who gets so
enraged and he does like it's scary I
list listen to me listen to me he gets
so enraged and he has figured out
something that that numbs that rage
alcohol yep and you're asking him when
you feel enraged don't go drive we have
to develop some different
behaviors right I'm asking you the same
thing your guilt and you're allowing him
to just keep doing whatever he wants to
do because you feel guilty hasn't worked
right right let's try something
else the greatest gift you can give him
is I love you I believe you that your
skin is on fire you cannot bring cocaine
into my
house I believe you that you are in pain
if you make a threat on your life I will
call the police 100% of the time every
time and that's not going to be your
Avenue to me that's going to be your
Avenue to a 72-hour
hold right an Avenue to me is you
walking in the front door and letting me
hold my
baby I don't care how old you are right
but if you act only as a response to the
guilt you feel nothing
changes yeah and by the way he has to go
get DBT dialectical behavior therapy he
has to choose that that's the path for
him okay and you can't do that for
him so what do I do in the future
because I can just see this cycling
around again that he's goingon to lose
his place where he's staying right now
and say I don't have any place to live
can I come home and I'm like how do you
look I know logically that I can say no
you can't but how do you emotionally the
emotional side my heart says how do you
tell your kid I'm sorry you can't come
live here you
grieve yeah you allow yourself to feel
it and in the same way you would tell
him hey hey hey hey
hey I know you are so angry about being
abandoned and you're about to go home
with those four women please don't this
will
pass I'll tell you the same
thing everything in your body will
scream at you let him come home let him
come home let him come
home that will
pass okay or you can come
home here are the
stipulations here are the boundaries
and be honest I've not held these in the
past and I learning that I have not done
you any
favors or you can come home first time
but you will enroll in
DBT and I would like to if you feel safe
I would like to um I would like you to
sign that I can have a conversation with
your counselor so I can see how you're
doing if you don't go right I hear you
that it's scary I hear you that it makes
you feel powerless and here's the truth
the truth is you can't live here unless
you are actively pursuing
care yep and I will tell you Mom
borderline personality disorder has a
high rate of success for treatment and
it is hell and it's
long because you basically have to learn
inside my body that what my body feels
in any given moment is not the
truth and that's just tough to to
reimagine I mean re-experience life
right
right that's hard hard hard he's got
he's got a tall Order ahead of him and
he can do
it yeah I'm just it's it was so
interesting because I felt like a
thousand pound weight lifted off me when
I finally heard that I was like I've
been throwing darts at a wall and now I
actually have a Target except here's the
problem here's the problem you don't
have a Target he
does right right you have been solving
his problems his whole life and you
can't solve this
one you're
right but I feel like at least it gives
it an identity and a name oh yeah we
named the dragon on this one yeah like
oh my gosh I'm not crazy nope because
you know he goes into his rages and
telling me how stupid dumb I am and you
know what I mean like you just feel like
an idiot but hold on that's when you
stop and say I'm going to stop
you I hear you that you're very mad I
believe
you you are not allowed to be
disrespectful in my house to me or your
father
period so if you choose to be
disrespectful you're choosing to
leave oh my gosh you in that I'm tell
I'm gonna stop you right there this is
your last
shot you're choosing to
leave I prefer you to stay I want you
here and by the way that interaction is
not going to solve this he's got to go
get very directed
therapy and it's hard it's hard he's got
to learn tolerance for that fire feeling
that he body feels like it's on fire but
it's actually
not yeah and then he's got to learn some
new
behaviors in place of the ones that are
impulsive and ultimately destructive
gotta retrain his body as to what feels
normal that's tough tough tough
tough so I can just continue to tell him
that I love him and I support him and
all day long I love you yeah that's one
of the most important things I see you I
see you and here's the truth can't do
that or you cannot live here I would be
honored if you would have dinner with me
every Wednesday night and lunch with me
every Sunday
afternoon right forget you if you're not
going to let me live I don't want
anything to do with you I hate that I
hear you and I know you're mad I hear
it but you can't live here but I would
really love it if I could buy you dinner
on Wednesdays and Sundays to catch up
see how you're
doing right and if you fulfill program
ABC and D I'd love to figure out helping
you get an apartment or helping you move
back in or I'd love to go to therapy
with
you see what I'm saying we're not
abandoning him which is his worst
nightmare right
we are saying I'll walk alongside you
but he doesn't get to dictate his his
volatility doesn't get to dictate this
relationship his stable mother and
father
do and over time hopefully that is
something he can anchor into
finally Because He Lives an
anchorless life and he's just whipped
around by feelings and by the way for
those of you like wondering like oh is
that real borderline personality
disorder is very very real and the
feelings the intensity is very
real I've seen it it is
wow deep compassion for folks who
struggle that and my goodness there some
of my favorite people on the
planet but again I don't have one that's
a child so I can walk out of a room be
like hey dude I'm not gonna do this but
I love you and when you're ready to to
hang out I would love to one of my
favorite people I've had students over
the years that were
brilliant and hilarious and so fun and
woo when things got sideways like it was
tough very very tough then deep shame
and all of it loop back here's what I'm
saying be
present let them know you see them and
you hear them and then you got to hold
firm on the
boundaries and it sounds like Mom it
would be good for you to go talk to
somebody too to have somebody walk
alongside you and give you some tips and
some support and some tools on how to
love somebody be in a relationship with
somebody that struggles with borderline
personality disorder it's very very
hard and let's set down the bricks of
guilt and what did I do what about me
let's let's let's let's don't do that
let's make it about what kind of home do
I want to have what are the boundaries I
want to build and how can I love and
support
him because my guess is Mom you didn't
do anything
wrong the truth is you got a hurting son
Let's head that way I'm grateful for you
Janelle thank you so so much for the
call